I want to talk about what happened in
London on Friday there was an explosion
on the district line train at Parsons
Green tube station to being of course
the British subway it's being treated as
a terrorist incident by London police 30
people were treated in hospitals or
urgent care centres
it was mostly burn injuries 19 of the 30
were taken to the hospital by ambulance
11 were in ok enough condition to take
themselves to the hospital or to urgent
care
Isis almost immediately claimed
responsibility through an affiliate but
that's really no surprise and amber Rudd
who's the Home Secretary in England says
that there's no evidence of any actual
connections to Isis beyond maybe you
know a shared ideology the perpetrators
were not initially apprehended so there
there was a manhunt an 18 year old and a
21 year old have so far been arrested
unclear whether these are the
perpetrators or were involved with the
incident in some way and what I want to
talk about is the true very real and
very serious danger that Donald Trump's
reaction to this event and two other
events are having Donald Trump tweeted
very shortly after the incident before
we really knew much at all about what
had happened quote another attack in
London by a loser terrorists these are
sick and demented people who were in the
sights of Scotland Yard must be
proactive this contains all sorts of
really dangerous stuff
first of all public criticism of a major
ally before we even have any information
it's a diplomacy disaster absolute
diplomacy disaster and for now
diplomacy still sort of matters British
Prime Minister Theresa May called the
comments not helpful you think that's
what she wants to be dealing with or
what we want to put her in the position
of having to deal with after a terrorist
attack in her country immediately
this causes Trump's lieutenants to have
to go and do damage control National
Security Adviser HR McMaster came out
and said what the president
was communicating is that obviously all
of our law enforcement efforts are
focused on this terrorist threat for
years what does that mean
adding Scotland Yard has been a leader
as our FBI has been a leader Trump then
followed up minutes later and we'll get
to some of his other tweets but this
brings us to the facts right is it true
that Scotland Yard had these
perpetrators in their sights we don't
know the answer to that if so was that
classified information again classified
information from an ally shared with us
not to be made public that Donald Trump
goes on Twitter and tweets but
interestingly enough the answer might
actually be a lot dumber than any of
that 23 minutes before Donald Trump
tweeted that Scotland Yard was aware of
these perpetrators Fox and Friends on
Fox News had a security analyst saying
that he feared that the London police
already had the identities of the
attackers feared that they might know
the identities is of course nothing like
have been tracking these particular
people for some time so either Trump is
spreading rumors that the attackers were
in the sites of Scotland Yard or he's
leaking information yet again that he
has no right to leak it's disturbing for
a 71 year old man to be doing this
particularly if he's President of the
United States minutes later Trump goes
back to Twitter as part of this demented
rant two minutes later and he tweets
trying to defend the travel ban saying
quote the travel ban into the United
States should be far larger tougher and
more specific but stupidly that would
not be politically correct based on what
was known then what actual data do we
have that the type of travel ban that
Donald Trump wants in the United States
would have actually prevented this
attack in London we have none but this
influences policy people see this stuff
and they believe yeah look at what
happened in London we should have the
travel ban hey just ban all travel right
I mean no one can blow anything up if
there aren't passengers and why wasn't
Donald Trump this mad about what
happened in Charlottesville then he
needed time to think calmly
about his response and then Donald Trump
to game at the internet saying on
Twitter quote loser terrorists must be
dealt with in a much tougher manner the
Internet is their main recruitment tool
which we must cut off and use better
hell yeah I mean ban the internet right
Pat that's how they recruit except for
the online stores where you can buy
Donald Trump's Magga hats that are made
in China other than that we've got to
shut down the internet for these folks
it's interesting that you bring up that
Charlottesville point too because he
said at that time that when he makes a
statement he wants to be correct and he
wants all the facts on the ground yeah
we're commenting on it remember he would
say the same thing over and over again
like there's good people on both sides
there's bad people on both sides not
here repeating himself trying to defuse
the situation but for this one he's
willing to rush to judgment minutes
after and minutes after he hears
something similar on Fox and Friends and
what really scares me about this is that
Trump is using sort of a failed I mean
30 people were injured it's terrible it
could have easily been much much worse
Trump is using an effectively failed
subway attack in London to justify a
ridiculous travel ban in the United
States what would Trump do if we
actually had and I hope we don't have it
a major domestic terrorist attack if he
uses a failed attack in London to
justify hairbrained policies what is the
guy capable of if we have a major attack
in the United States this is not
American exceptionalism this is the
growing realization from foreign powers
both friendly and unfriendly that Donald
Trump is a live wire that he can't be
trusted and that's something that our
allies Trump doing this after a close
ally has an incident allies would see
this and rightly say we've got a
distance from the u.s. we just don't
need this right now and it's also
something that plays into the hands of
our adversaries our adversaries would
also use against Trump that the guy is
unhinged and can't control what he says
in social media the Twitter rant when
you read it pat and you consider there's
been an attack in London right if you
take a tweet in isolation it's easy to
write it off and say it's Trump being
Trump he says what's on it's on his mind
except when it's Charlottesville and it
would make sense to be quiet for days
the rant in total is the ranting of a
true madman lunatic that's the reality
of it I really think that he could avoid
half of the trouble that he gets into if
he just deleted the Twitter account or
delegated it off to someone else and why
is he continues to beat himself over the
head with this it's just unforced errors
time and time again that applies to the
Russia investigation right I've talked
about that a lot of what's going on with
Russia is related either directly or
indirectly to subjects that Donald Trump
has broached on Twitter if you saw your
local supermarket manager tweeting stuff
like this on Twitter you'd look at
replacing the supermarket manager
because it's unhinged and it really
doesn't look good this is the President
of the United States who was going on
these rants and still has and actually
you know his his approval rating has
been ticking up I don't know if he
really did this oh it's disturbing I
looked at the Gallup daily tracking poll
he hit a low there of about thirty four
thirty five percent it has been steadily
higher I mean it's still not great right
but it's been solidly close to 40 now
for about ten or so days I might talk
about this tomorrow I don't know yet
but there there is a contingent of the
country that is not going to turn on
Donald Trump and that's why we can't
wait for people to just wake up right I
mean we were waiting for people to wake
up all of the george w bush's first term
guy got reelected maybe it's because
he's been working with democrats a
little bit more and i think it had been
a little bit of time since his last
twitter rant yeah any time that you can
get some distance from twitter that's
worth a one and a half to two and a half
approval points no doubt about it this
is really scary and it's not about you
know i know we like to put up tweets and
we laugh right because it's also silly
that this should be concerning to
everybody this is now a national
security concern for the United States
Donald Trump treating allies in ways
that if we were them we would say look
at how we're being treated by the
President of the United States we need
to stop sharing information with them we
need to reconsider our alliance with
those countries and I know that there
are trumpets who believe we don't need
anybody else we're the best and Trump
can do it all in our national security
and military we can do it all but this
is a an entire planet and we do actually
need
support and alliances that we have and
seeing Donald Trump single-handedly
destroy them day after tweet after day
after tweet should scare all of us
because what because of what it means
for the future of the United States
discuss this with us on reddit david
pakman.com slash re d di t supporting
the show today we have independent
artist types from Grand Rapids Michigan
with the war EP it is a multi genre
progressive humanists response to the
ongoing culture war in America I love a
good political album here's a clip from
the song apocalypse horse
[Music]
very cool you can hear the song in its
entirety at types that's types with
forties Bandcamp calm you can also find
the exclusive demos and live recordings
on the types patreon and YouTube pages
both of which also have four T's and you
can find out more at types Bandcamp com